quel est dans le maïs 5 mai à toulouse
le 26
ah non le 29 mai à l'olympia de bacchus
toujours la ps1 toujours toujours plus
qu'avant on aimerait vous savez en forme
ouais ouais c'est les enfants ces
enfants et ces je me lève tôt je prends
un peu soin de soi non moi je fais ma
des crèmes de nuit quand même non mais
j'ai changé les couches mais nadal a
battu voire même alors là quelle est la
situation s'est calmée à qu'akhenaton
dit moi je change les couches donc là je
mène à l'école moi aussi je mène à
l'école alors pourquoi justement il n'y
a pas eu d'émeutes à marseille au parce
que marseille est une ville particulière
au niveau de l'identité en tout cas les
marseillais en ce côté c'est dur à dire
mais oui se sentent marseillais avant d'
avant d'être français y'a pas l'y a pas
de pierres d'un format mais vraiment
mais vraiment et aussi merci c'était une
ville qui vit énormément de
du temps où il y avait des colonies donc
à la décolonisation cette ville qui
s'effondre et industriellement haut
niveau de l'état créé un secteur
tertiaire énorme pour sinon aujourd'hui
on aurait 30 % et 32 % de chômage à
marseille donc en parallèle assez
développé énormément de l'association
les associations anti c'est une sorte de
filet sur toute la ville et je vous
garantis que les gens sur le terrain
c'est souvent me dit des hommes
politiques veulent me rencontrer où on
me demande mais alors vous avez fait du
bon boulot en mars et j'y vais c'est pas
moi si vous voulez rencontrer des gens
bien vous en présente vingt trois et
forcément ils n'ont pas trop envie de le
rencontrer à eux ils veulent rencontrer
du people il ya aussi le grand
banditisme
et oui je voulais pas trop en parler oui
ça existe oui ça existe ça aussi ça
tient quand même parce que j'étais gros
une caisse
là où ça va les voitures ne brûle pas
voilà voilà
ouais mais à marseille je pense quand
même il ya la volonté toujours de
prendre le contre-pied de paris moi ça
me frappe parce que je suis un peu comme
ça m'a fait cadeau de sinsemilia nm de
paris très forte dans l'impression des
émeutes déployés d'avoir à marseille le
jour ce sera très calme appareils quoi
s'est il y en a eu il y en a eu dans les
années 80 d'ailleurs un sociologue
lillois qui disait que marseille avait
29 ans au niveau social et des grands
maîtres au début des années 80 il avait
fait des citations esaü en plus des des
émeutes ethniques où il y avait eu des
sortes de guérilla entre les gitans les
érables savait était bien choisi enfin
bon laboratoire je trouve pour la france
parce que marseille ait pas de ghetto
1-1 en fait c'est que ça s'est il ya des
quartiers très dit gris et les quartiers
coûter bonbon qu'ailleurs oui bien sûr
il n'y a pas le côté comme à paris c'est
à dire les ghettos sur les côtés ou dans
beaucoup de grandes villes c'est pas une
grande ville occidentale c'est à dire
avec un centre ville très riche et les
quartiers ouais ouais mais
bien qu'à new york ça change les
promoteurs sont moins basse sur harlem
s'entraîne découvert l'europe en partant
à new york c'est voir son oncle jean à
moi j'ai toute ma famille nous y aurait
miami los angeles
elle hérite althusser alors tu es
musulman soit oui tu as réagi comment
aux caricatures de mahomet je les trouve
aussi laide qui le caricaturent qui
était fait sur les juges dans les années
30 dans la nuit près nazi je trouve que
c'est cesser de ces racistes
c'est gratuit et ça n'arrange rien à la
situation c'est pour ça que j'ai dit
à travers ce genre de caricatures là on
nous somme de choisir notre camp donc il
ya des caricatures pourquoi s'il avait
vraiment envie de caricaturer pourquoi
ils n'ont pas pris les mollahs ils
pouvaient encore caricaturer ahmadinéjad
où les mots là ça pose aucun problème du
moment caricature mahomet on prend tous
les musulmans et on les met tous dans le
même sac et c'est ce que je dis des fois
on a l'impression depuis septembre 2001
moi j'ai l'impression n'est pas de me
réveiller le matin au mollah omar qui
dort à côté de mon lit ça me fait chier
comme ça il me regarde
j'ai envie de me débarrasser de cangé
quand j'étais quand j'étais jeune à la
fin des années soixante dix il y avait
un type un dessinateur qui s'appelait
gotlib et je me souviens j'ai été nourri
par ça et c'est les bandes dessinées de
gotlib que c'était cp y avait tous les
dieux il y avait il y avait moïse il y
avait dû y avait il ya vait mahomet il y
avait jésus-christ et il faisait 10
d'immenses partout 6 bourré la gueule et
tout et personne ne disait rien personne
n'était scandalisé moi je suis très
frappé par sa tout le monde se marrait
tout le monde se marrait je suis
d'accord avec toi quand tu es scandalisé
parce que ces caricatures moi je trouve
nulle résidus des objets mais en même
temps en même temps en aveyron par
exemple qu'on est dans une année dans
une société où ce genre il ya des gens
qui ont le droit qui doivent pouvoir
avoir le droit de republier ces
caricatures et voilà c'est ça le croit
le débat qui a là dedans c'est que mal
par exemple au point quand on a vu ces
caricatures on a dit benjamin va publier
ça c'est pas mais on ne va pas les
publier d'accord mais en tant d'autres
journaux doivent avoir le droit de les
publier sans que ça fasse d'issoire moi
je sais on vit quand même dans des
sociétés on doit pouvoir tout dire et
tout faire un
mais voilà ça c'est vrai que s'il ya des
gens qui ont envie de le faire qu'ils le
fassent après j'aimerais bien que
l'opinion publique au nom de la liberté
d'expression n'aille pas dans une
opinion qui qui est libertaire au départ
et qui finit par être fascisante à la
fin ledent même d'un traitement de
l'information on voit que médiatiquement
le meurtre de chaïb qui a eu lieu ces
derniers jours qui est un meurtre
raciste a fait un soir de nos
informations et il ya vraiment un
problème
il ya un problème général justement par
la dernière fois que je suis venu à
l'émission de vulgarisation sur l'islam
on a sept millions de musulmans en
france jamais le film le message est un
film de paix avec anthony quinn il n'est
jamais passé ne serait ce que sur un
service public on a un problème on a un
petit problème qui est qui et à régler
pour moi j'accepte qui est déjà raté qui
ne croient pas en dieu
il faut que les gens acceptent aussi qui
est des gens qui peuvent être blessés
des gens vous savez par exemple mes
beaux-parents qu'ici les gens vous venez
chez eux ils dorment par terre pour vous
laisser dormir dans leurs lits ils vous
reçoivent chez deux mais vraie mentalité
ces caricatures ces caricatures les
hommes blessés
ne serait ce que pour ces gens là ne
serait ce que pour les vrais mecs déjà
un truc en goodies ces caricatures c'est
vraiment des caricatures il croyait on
est d'accord il faut croyez pas les
situer le problème qu'il ya je pense que
ce que je comprends pas dire souvent
dans une partie du monde musulman qui a
d'habitude victimaire il dit non non non
on doit pas faire ça mais bien entendu
est d'ailleurs le monde musulman
n'aurait pas gueuler c'est caricatural à
une personne en avait parlé et je trouve
ça a été beaucoup mieux qu'on n'en parle
pas comme d'ailleurs on ne parle pas de
certaines caricatures sur g en un
isolement qui avait laissé les gens qui
ressemblent aux gens qui font les
caricatures non je vois le même d'en
faire autant je parle pas du monde
musulman enfin je parle du monde
musulman
enfin toutes ces manifestations qui a eu
nationaux crois pas que ce cas de plus
insultant pour l'islam beaucoup plus que
les caricatures c'est les types qui
donnent des images à la télévision quand
il égorge des des otages au nom de
l'islam
tu crois pas que c'est beaucoup plus
insultant pour l'islam et il était beau
parent où ils doivent être beaucoup plus
humiliés et beaucoup plus instrument qui
remarque jean là bas où je parle en a au
caricaturiste on est là on n'aime pas on
en parle on le dit pas pourquoi les
musulmans ne juge pas pourquoi il se
révolte toi contre ces gens là et sur
qui le disent mais le problème c'est que
le système médiatique est telle qu'on a
en france donne 99,9 pour cent du temps
de parole à ces gens là où du temps
d'image à ces gens là on médiatise la
peur aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui est
médiatisé sur l'islam pourquoi ribes
l'islam à quel moment le viennent dans
l'histoire des religions ces images je
sais j'ai lu marcel gaucher mois donc à
quel moment à gages je sais que ça
revient après la grande transgression
chrétienne sais pas c'est pas innocent
c'est une réforme du c'est une réforme
de la de la chrétienneté mais ces
grandes religions monothéistes et le
grand à chiba aujourd'hui la chance
d'affronter profonde beaucoup de gens à
papa à l'image des des terroristes et
des otages il croit que ça y est me
trashy toi et tu fais bien on le voit
d'ailleurs on le voit marseille on le
voit à paris moi je sais pas ce que j'ai
une amie musulmane un jour il avait un
problème
affreux comme ça dans sa vie qui est sûr
dans la première église est allé prier
le même dieu mais c'est ça qu'il faut
donner il ya les musulmans sincères avec
l'islam on en parle souvent à travers
des des jeux au langage avec des choses
positives
alors quand le rappeur monsieur r 10 la
france est une garce n'oublie pas de la
baiser jusqu'à l'épuiser comme une
[ __ ]
je suis pas d'accord avec cette même de
même
même si il a envie de passer un message
moi je connais monsieur je pense que
c'est que ces phrases là je reconnais
pas là la personne que j'aime bien ces
phases là mais malheureusement il
s'instaure une sorte de marketing direct
du choc et de la peur est que les
certains de l'aed est inouïe mais oui du
marketing de la haine de la faune
maritime et marketing de la haine des
immigrés aussi honorable pour le
français si j'ai bien et c'est une
partie de ping pong tout à fait c'est
une partie de ping pong ok ok ouais il
faut voir mais il faut pas excusé
justement les hommes politiques ont une
responsabilité au delà des rappeurs les
propos de monsieur sarkozy ce week-end
sur lamentable quand il dit quand une
bande de jeunes torturent un jeune homme
jusqu'à jusqu'à le cul et le mot
racaille bien faible il prend deux
situations où il ya eu un acte de
banditisme suivi d'un acte de racisme où
il ya un jeune homme qui se fait tuer il
prend sa visite à argenteuil où il ya
des gamins de 16 ans qui l'insultent sur
le parvis
il fait il mélange et le jette à l'eau
visage de la france en disant que
finalement dans les quartiers des
tortionnaires potentiel c'est exactement
ça c'est pareil excusez moi quand même
quelqu'un katia carlier qui a une
émission qui est quand même une personne
intelligente c'est ça c'est nous sommes
censés être bête et pas avoir fait
d'études c'est une personne intelligente
qui reçoit un ancien skinhead sur le
plateau qui disent moi ça y est j'ai
trouvé ma paie je me suis converti à
l'islam jeunes et femmes marocaines j'ai
bien j'ai trouvé mon équilibre et 10
faudrait pas basculer d'une extrême à
une autre mais tu te rends compte sur la
même ligne cette personne là mais la
religion musulmane et les skinheads
d'extrême droite
c'est gravissime de dire des choses
comme ça et voulait pas qu'on se sente
choqué nous on répond avec un emballage
différent de monsieur r mais fermement
et radicalement aussi il faut qu'il faut
que ce pays-là réalise qu'on est là
parce que sinon vous ne voyez pas aussi
que c'est l'islam doit faire sa
révolution c'est à dire qu'il doit se
terminer à la modernité de la
on est de l'individu au nez du temps la
femme au vote depuis quarante-six france
a mis deux cent cinquante ans à faire
ces révolutions il faut donner du temps
c'est de l'argent qui seront munis de
bombes placées vrai mais c'est une
révolution nécessaire il faut que bien
sûr que les intellectuels musulmans
fassent la révolution ali a déjà été
dans l'histoire de oui mais elle a
échoué non ll l appel n'a pas échoué
elle a basculé au xiiie siècle avec moi